1m4 has basically been the clear
favorite over the other the M4A1 excels
at nearly every single category first
the a1s was overpowered as hell then for
like 60 years it was the loud variant
then in 2021 valve buffed the silencer's
body damage making it a death ray for
over a year before reducing its range
modifier in the fall of 2022 and now for
the first time in a decade they're on
equal footing according to hltv the
recent blast spring group stage saw the
m4a1s and the m4a4 reach one of if not
the closest states of parity Pro CS go
has ever seen the a1s barely eat the A4
app which isn't what anyone expected
since it was just nerfed Emporium is I
still play with it I think M4 A4 will be
more popular now that could be because
the a1s is still a tad better but who's
to say simple simples to say you're
doing some Eco and you have 2.9 and you
always know that you can easily buy the
same four but with m4a4 it knows that
it's